good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight you hate to start a
Tuesday evening on a grim note but one
of the environmental catastrophes one of
the great environmental catastrophes of
our time is unfolding tonight off the
coast of Denmark the nordstream
pipelines which are enormous
russian-owned conduits that carry
natural gas from Russia to Western
Europe have been breached as we speak
nordstream 1 and nordstream 2 are
pouring millions of cubic meters of
natural gas into the Baltic Sea
pictures from the air which you can now
see on your screen show a toxic bubble
field more than half a mile wide you can
only guess at how many marine mammals
are being killed right now countless
but the lasting damage may be to the
atmosphere natural gas is comprised of
up to 90 percent methane methane as Joe
Biden has often told you is the key
driver of global warming which is of
course an existential threat to humanity
in the planet so if you're worried about
climate change what just happened to the
Nordstrom pipelines is as close to the
apocalypse as we have ever come
so the question is how did this happen
and it turns out it was not an accident
at the very same time that leaks in
these pipelines were detected Swedish
officials recorded two powerful undersea
explosions each one of which was
equivalent to hundreds of pounds of TNT
nothing in nature can account for that
almost immediately the pipelines began
leaking in three separate places so
there's only one explanation for what
happened this was an act of industrial
terrorism that was very obvious to the
prime minister of Poland and he wasted
no time in saying so watch
today we are also dealing with an act of
sabotage we do not know the details of
what happened yet but we can clearly see
that it is an act of sabotage an act
that probably marks the next stage in
the escalation of the situation we are
dealing with in Ukraine
we can clearly see he said this was an
act of sabotage an act of terrorism well
yes we can see that so the question is
who did it and of course the prime
suspect is obvious would be the same man
who caused domestic inflation here in
the U.S and stole the 2016 election from
Hillary Clinton that be Vladimir V Putin
The Washington Post got right to it
Putin they declared is now weaponizing
the Nordstrom Pipelines according to the
Canadian ambassador to the U.N Vladimir
Putin has decided to use quote pollution
as an act of War
Progressive Twitter strongly endorsed
this conclusion Putin did it and that
makes sense until you thought about it
for just a moment Vladimir Putin may be
evil they tell us that he is evil but is
he stupid probably isn't stupid and yet
and here's the strange part if you are
Vladimir Putin you would have to be a
suicidal [ __ ] to blow up your own
energy pipelines that's the one thing
you would never do
natural gas pipelines are the main
source of your power and your wealth and
most critically your leverage over other
countries Europe needs your energy now
more than ever with winter approaching
if you can't deliver that energy then
countries like Germany have no need to
pay attention to what you want you're in
the middle of a war an all hands on deck
Wars you need all the leverage you can
get
under these circumstances there is no
chance you would blow up nordstream one
or two not now obviously
in fact it's so obvious that even our
famously dim Secretary of State Tony
blinken seemed to acknowledge it
sabotaging Nordstrom he said today is
quote clearly in no one's interest
right but really only half right it is
true that blowing up Nordstrom does not
help Vladimir Putin he would not do that
why would he but that doesn't mean that
other countries wouldn't consider doing
it they would consider it and we know
they have considered it because at least
one of them has said so in public
in early February less than three weeks
before the war in Ukraine began Joe
Biden suggested on camera that he might
take out these pipelines watch
if Russia invades that means tanks or
troops crossing the uh the the border of
Ukraine again then there will be uh we
there will be no longer a Norse team too
we we will bring an end to it
and control of the project is within
Germany's control
you will uh I promise you we'll be able
to do it
notice how he phrased that he's the
president doesn't phrase things by
accident particularly when he's reading
off cards he didn't say I will pause the
delivery of gas from Russia to Germany
he said there won't be a Nordstrom too
we'll put an end to it we'll take it out
we'll blow it up
how will you do this he was asked I
promise you we will be able to do it
they thought this through
and yet those watching very much
including us didn't take Biden seriously
when he said it this is the president
who's declared climate change the most
pressing emergency in the history of the
world this is the man who lectures you
about using a wood stove or driving an
SUV because of its emissions this is the
guy who spent billions trying to
mitigate cow flatulence because methane
would that guy really blow up a methane
pipeline in the middle of the Baltic Sea
it was hard to imagine that would be an
unimaginably Reckless act that'd be the
kind of thing you would do if you wanted
to start a nuclear war it would be
insane
and yet in retrospect it's obvious they
were thinking about this because Joe
Biden wasn't the only person to suggest
it Toria Newland at the state department
said pretty much the very same thing
Newland is a lifelong War cheerleader
she worked to bring about the Iraq
invasion never apologized kept going she
helped engineer the coup that overthrew
the Ukrainian government some years back
so capable clearly she's capable of
anything
but environmental terrorism
even for Toria Newland that seemed too
much too extreme and yet here she is in
January
with regard to Nordstrom too
we continue to have a very strong and
clear conversations with our German
allies and I want to be clear with you
today if Russia invades Ukraine one way
or another Nordstrom 2 will not move
forward
one way or the other we'll stop
Nordstrom
now looking back those words seem
chilling eight months later as natural
gas pours into the Baltic Sea and into
the atmosphere so you have to ask could
the bite Administration really do
something like this
we can't say for sure we don't know for
sure we can tell you that close allies
of the Biden White House believe they
certainly did do it
Roddick Sikorsky is a Polish politician
he's chairman of the EU USA delegation
in the European Parliament he's
connected he's also the husband of
regime's stenographer and Applebaum of
the Atlantic magazine Sikorsky is so
close to Joe Biden he's got a picture of
the two of them together in his Twitter
profile so when the pipelines blew up
Sikorsky responded immediately and
here's what he wrote thank you USA
so once again did the Biden
Administration really do this it's hard
to believe given that it's an atrocity
it's effectively an act of terrorism we
don't want to make that accusation
but we should tell you that maybe not
coincidentally today a brand new
pipeline was unveiled a pipeline that
carries non-russian natural gas in
roughly the same areas Nordstrom's one
and two this is called the Baltic pipe
it was inaugurated in Poland it will
carry natural gas from Norway through
Denmark to Poland and other countries
nearby
and it's likely to do very well since
now it has less competition
making sense
what does the White House say about this
how are they accounting for what
happened today well they're not exactly
enthusiastically denying responsibility
for it instead they're looking at the
upside here's the president's publicist
noting that the destruction of yet
another energy pipeline is yet another
opportunity for you to buy an electric
car
as you all know these pipelines weren't
pumping gas into Europe at this time ns2
was never operational as you guys know
ns1 has not been operational for weeks
because Putin has weaponized energy and
we have said this many times before the
just drives home the importance of our
efforts to work together to get
alternative gas supplies to Europe and
to support efforts to reduce gas
consumption and accelerate true energy
independence by moving to clean energy
economy
oh moving to clean energy say the people
who very May well be responsible
for letting methane
into the Baltic Sea and into the
atmosphere at a scale that most people
can't imagine
the people lecturing you about your SUV
may have blown up a natural gas pipeline
and created one of the great
catastrophes
of our time
in its effect on the environment if they
did this this will be one of the
craziest most destructive things any
American Administration has ever done
but it would also be totally consistent
with what they do what do they do they
destroy these people build nothing not
one thing instead they tear down and
they desecrate from historic statues to
the Constitution to energy
infrastructure
and no one in Congress is trying to stop
any of it
they're just preparing for the
inevitable Fallout tonight the Senate
just Advanced a spending bill with 35
million for the Department of energy to
quote prepare for and respond to
potential nuclear and radiological
incidents in Ukraine what
the spending Bill also brings the total
U.S expenditure on Ukraine the war but
also funding its government and energy
for Ukraine
to 67 billion dollars on the eve of what
could be a massive economic disruption
here to our economy 67 billion dollars
how much is that well it's more than
Russia's entire military budget last
year and Congress is expected to fully
pass the bill later this week with
Republicans nodding along like the
zombies they are
what will be the effect of this every
action has a reaction equal and opposite
blow up the nordstream pipelines okay
we've entered a new phase one in which
the United States is directly at war
with the largest nuclear power in the
world doesn't mean it'll go nuclear
immediately but it does suggest there
could be consequences if we actually
blew up the north dream pipelines why
wouldn't Russia sever undersea internet
cables what would happen if they did
that what would happen if banks in
London couldn't communicate with banks
in New York just that one piece of it
leaving aside its potential effects on
our power grid but let's just say the
banks couldn't communicate with each
other for one day
well the economic effect of that be or
we would Cascade downward into your
house
we could have an actual collapse we
could wind up very quickly in third
world conditions
those are the stakes
have the people behind this the Geniuses
like Toria Newland considered the
effects maybe they have maybe that was
the point subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight